with arts now lost to the world we
transformed a tiny outpost into
Dragonstone a fortress fit for the last
dragon lords then a nas descendant
settled into it like a tomb for their
lost homeland until Aegon when he looked
east he saw the past old tired dead but
when he lived west he saw the future
gold in the ground gold in the fields
and no dragons in the sky but his he and
his sisters Rhaenys and Visenya flew
over the great continent ostensibly
visitors to a strange land but when
Aegon returned he ordered construction
of a massive table carved in the shape
of Westeros with all the notable rivers
and mountains that they had seen a
personal map of the Seven Kingdoms then
ruled by seven squabbling families
house-door ndon held the Stormlands from
their seated storm's end due south of
Dragonstone house horror of the Iron
Islands had also conquered and enslaved
the Riverlands and ruled them from
Harrenhal
a monstrous castle rising on the shore
of the Gods aye
how stark held the frozen wasteland of
the North the oldest largest and
emptiest of the kingdom has Lannister
held the westerland's the wealthiest
Kingdom
thanks to their gold mines house
gardener held the reach of the second
wealthiest Kingdom thanks to their crops
as Aaron held the Vale or rather the
Vale held them the mountains were
impossible except through the bloody
gate which had never been taken house
Martell held the deserts of dome from
the plate because no one else wanted
them together the Seven Kingdoms made
Westeros a realm that wasn't yet around
ruled by great families who didn't know
what greatness was Aegon would teach
them welcome back everybody big surprise
HBO just confirmed that there's a brand
new game of Thrones prequel series about
the Targaryen family the pilot is
getting ready to shoot next year so
we'll break it all down the new sights
and all the trades are reporting its
Aegon's conquest but fire and blood
covers a really big period up to the
dance of the Dragons so I'll explain
that during the video if you're new to
my channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos of course I'll be doing
episode videos for this when it
eventually gets here I'll talk about
expected timelines and potential release
dates including the other Game of
Thrones prequel Blood Moon that they're
working on right now that's right we're
heading to a place where we might have
two Game of Thrones series running at
the same time but that's still a little
ways off the Aegon's conquest teaser is
narrated by Viserys Targaryen himself
that covers the doom of Valyria up
through Aegon's conquest so very early
in the rise of the Targaryen family in
Westeros although the way the trades in
the news sites are reporting it they're
talking about it chronicling the
beginning of the end of the Targaryen
family so that also implies they'll deal
with the reign of the dragon that gets
into fire and blood the book so I'll
explain how they divide that up the way
they're talking about it too is that it
was actually the prequel series that
Bryan cogman who wrote on the show for
every single one of the seasons was
working on but then they passed on I
don't know what his take on that period
was but they're saying that the new
showrunner that's coming in and working
with George art Martin is doing a
completely different take on this era
after Bryan cogman pilot deal with HBO
fell through he went to work with the
Amazon Lord of the
Rings prequel series which is going to
be set during the Second Age and cover
the period when Sauron was tricking the
elves into forging the rings of power we
don't have a release date for that yet
but it's supposed to start shooting
early next year most of you reply at
least a little familiar with Aegon's
conquest he's known for conquering the
Seven Kingdoms uniting Westeros but
technically he did not conquer Dorne so
he really only conquered six kingdoms
the ruler in Dorne during that period
was Princess Maria Martel so she didn't
get her sword melted down into the iron
throne like the other conquered lands it
was until eight generations later that
Dorne joined the other six kingdoms and
even then it was only after Aegon's
descendant Darren the first successfully
invaded but then was murdered and his
successor Bale or the first the guy who
was known for building the great Sept of
Baelor that we saw in the TV show the
one that Cersei blew up at the end of
season six wanted to end the conflict so
he forged a pact with Dorne and that's
what finally brought it into the other
Seven Kingdoms usually when people talk
about Aegon's conquest they leave that
fact out just because they want to talk
about him like he was this great figure
but obviously they do him on a series
you're gonna get a much more complex
picture of who he really was and they
get into that during the fire and blood
book the modern time line AC refers to
Aegon's conquest so they start the
modern calendar when they think that he
actually conquered the Seven Kingdoms
but really it took over two years to
complete so there's a lot of question as
to when he actually first made landfall
at the Blackwater rush which is now the
location where King's Landing is they
call it King's Landing
because after Aegon decided to conquer
the Seven Kingdoms that was the place
where he first made landfall with his
initial army there isn't a whole lot of
the fire and blood book that covers pre
doom Valyria you just get a brief
prologue then you find out about a nor
Targaryen who was head of the family
when they left to go to Dragonstone
fleeing the doom of Valyria because of
the dream that Danis the dreamer had the
person that Daenerys is named for in
present-day
fun fact to balerion the black dread
biggest dragon in Westeros II history
you've seen all these pictures of him
heard about how great and terrible he
was he was hatched before the Targaryens
fled the doom of Valyria to Dragonstone
and when they took their family and all
their holdings they brought five dragons
with them but the only one of those five
dragons that survived to the time when
Aegon was born and grew up was balerion
the black dread the Dragons that his
sister
Road fagor and myrrh axes were hatched
on Dragonstone so they were much much
younger than blaring the black dread
still a lot of theories about there
being clutches the dragon eggs hidden
underneath dragon stone in the caves
clearly the main show was not concerned
with any of that stuff they were gonna
leave that for the other spin-off series
we know a lot about Targaryen history
predating Aegon the conquerer though
before Aegon was born to most of the
money that the Targaryens made was on
the passing trade ships that passed
through the drift mark between the
mainland and Dragonstone
but as the teaser says Aegon spent a lot
of time flying his dragons around
Westeros before he decided to conquer
the Seven Kingdoms
there were always all kinds of ongoing
feuds and minor battles between all the
different kingdoms of Westeros but Aegon
didn't get the idea to conquer the Seven
Kingdoms until the worst to offenders
started a really big conflict Harrenhal
also known as hair in the black in
Argyll actor and and also known as our
galactic n't great nicknames sound like
totally level-headed rulers so King
Haran has slowly been annexing more and
more land for himself from our Galax
territory he ruled in this area up here
around King's Landing in the Riverlands
and it started to take more and more
land from King orga lakh who ruled over
the area known as the storm lands in
present-day
some of what is now the reach all south
of the Blackwater rush River in order to
stop King here in the black from taking
more of his territory and pushing
further south Argyll a creech tout to
Aegon Targaryen and offered him his
daughter in marriage in a giant section
of the land north east of storms end
bordering on herons territory
he knew that Aegon had three dragons and
he wanted to create this dragon buffer
between his land and the storm lands in
King harren the black Aegon had already
gone full sister-wives and married his
two sisters and noticed that the land
that our galacon
offered him as part of the dowry had
already belonged to Haran the black for
a very long period his counteroffer to
Argyll a kin exchange for his help
was that he would grant him a much
bigger portion of the Stormlands all the
way down to what is now the reach
instead of him marrying our Galax
daughter he offered the hand of his
champion or espera thean and his
childhood friend bastard of a gods
father so technically he was the Gendry
Baratheon of that period and then after
Aegon's conquest he was given the
Stormlands started house Baratheon which
now in present-day Gendry Baratheon has
reclaimed for him
self fun Easter Egg to eventually horas
was captured during a Dornish conflict
and had his sword hand chopped up so he
became known as Horus the one hand his
son was named Davos he found alongside a
savage Samwell Tarly during a later war
with the Dornish outlaw so it is a
george RR martin type of trope where
names recur over time and you notice
familiar things in present-day the way
the fire and blood book breaks up all
this Targaryen history that they'll be
covering on the show it starts with the
targa and conquest obviously the
conquest of Westeros then there's the
piece of the dragon which is all about
Aegon's reign after his conquest then
there's a section called the sons the
dragon which focuses on the lives of
Aegon sons King Ennis the first and King
may Gore Targaryen maegor the cruel he's
the one that actually built the dragon
pit after blowing up the great Sept of
his time
Cersei style then there's a section
called the heirs of the dragon which
deals with Jo Harris the first after Mae
cores rein then there's a section called
the dying of the Dragons which overlaps
with the dance of the Dragons period the
Targaryen Civil War then the last
section of the book deals with the
aftermath in the early reign of the boy
King Aegon the third who reigned after
the dance of the Dragons so the prequel
series could cover a lot of different
things but everyone is just quoting
Aegon's conquest so for now that's what
I'm assuming is going to be if they
shoot the pilot next year year turning
around we could see the show by 2021 but
don't expect it any faster than that
they haven't officially greenlit the
Blood Moon prequel but it sounds like
they're liking the material so if they
green like that start working on more
episodes they could get that out by
early 2021 but when they drop some new
teasers or we get really big info I'll
totally do an update video if you have
any big questions about what's going on
with these new series just write them in
the comments below while you wait for
everything click here for all my Game of
Thrones Easter egg videos and click here
for that brand new watchman HBO teaser
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight